many americans as you see are frustrated
with a capital f at the lack of
government action following these
attacks and one familiar political
figure in texas brought his frustration
to uvalde yesterday that's democratic
candidate for governor beto o'rourke who
confronted republican governor greg
abbott accusing him of doing nothing
the former senate and presidential
candidate was shouted down by other
officials at o'keefe is at the white
house with more on the story
[Applause]
in the midst of a news conference led by
texas republican governor greg abbott on
the uvalde shooting suddenly his
democratic opponent beta o'rourke rose
to confront him this is the place to
talk too so this is totally predictable
sir you're out of line
sir you are online i'm sure you are out
of line please leave this auditorium
local officials including the mayor of
ufaldi called to get him kicked out i
can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] when it comes to a deal like this
to make a political issue
[Music]
this is on you until you choose to do
something o'rourke who trails abbott in
polls and called for a ban on
military-style assault weapons during
his failed 2020 presidential bid later
explained why he showed up we've got to
stand up to this or we just accept this
theater and business as usual and we
accept the next shooting and in
washington senate democrats say they'll
try again to pass gun safety legislation
already passed in the house please damn
it please think if it was your child or
grandchild but the legislation lacks the
necessary support as many republicans
say gun restrictions won't stop mass
violence any weapons dangerous any
firearm is potentially dangerous in the
hands of a deranged lunatic at the end
of the day the issue here is not the
firearm the texas shooting coincided
with a previously scheduled confirmation
hearing for stephen dettelbach the lead
the bureau of alcohol tobacco firearms
and explosives an agency that
investigates gun crimes and hasn't had a
permanent boss in seven years i vow to
never let politics in any way influence
my action as atf director
as for governor abbott he's scheduled to
appear friday at the national rifle
association's previously scheduled
meetings in houston but when asked
yesterday whether he still plans to
attend he wouldn't say somebody who is
still planning to appear is former
president donald trump
gail
all right ed thank you very much